Translator: Queenie Lee
Reviewer: Elisabeth Buffard
Somewhere deep inside,
you know what kind of person
you were designed to be.
If you want to produce great acorns,
think like an oak, not like an acorn.
Think like the person
you intend to become,
like the Christian question:
what would Jesus do?
Ask yourself, how would
the person I'd like to be
do the things I am about to do.
The acorn has three parts:
it's got a stem, a cap, and a seed.
And the stem represents
its connection to the past,
all the acorns, all the oaks
that have ever existed in its line before
are encoded in that,
transferred through that stem,
the legacy into this acorn.
The cap holds onto the seed
until the seed is ready
to grow on its own,
so the cap represents your coaches,
your mentors, your role models,
your guides, your parents,
your friends, your teachers.
And when you're ready
to grow on your own,
the seed of that acorn
holds not only your potential
but the potential
of every future generation of acorns
that will spring from that line.
So let me ask you a question.
What kind of seed is in you?
See, I believe part of our responsibility
in life is to find out who we are,
to discover ourselves.
First off, we need to respect our nature.
We need to realize
we are part of a continuing chain
that carries a legacy
and a responsibility.
And if that's the case,
then we need to recognize
that we were not biological coincidences.
I believe there is a creator,
and I believe you were intentionally
created for a myriad of purposes.
There are many things
we can do with our lives,
and I think it's our job to find out
what those things are
and to do them as well as we possibly can
so that we're passing
along the right imprint
for the next generation.
And that's just simply my life philosophy,
that's the way I look at it.
So first, we need to respect our nature.
Second, we need to know our nature.
Take Aristotle's advice, "Know thyself,"
but know things about yourself
that most people don't discover.
For example,
know how you're smart,
not just how smart you are
in comparison to others.
In what ways are you smart?
Know what you care about.
What are the values
that motivate your choices?
Know what your personal velocity is,
the intensity and drive
with which you naturally operate.
Know the background imprint,
positive, neutral or negative,
that you carry with you
and what effect it's had on you.
Know your behavioral style,
how you come across to other people.
Know the patterns in your choices
so that you're continually
learning more and more
about what it's like to be you,
so you can do an even better job of it.
And then we need to apply our nature,
we need to nurture our nature
by expressing ourselves in the world.
See, I never expected
to be anything but ordinary.
I was raised to be nice and ordinary.
I expected I would grow up to be -
my dad worked for the phone company,
I figured I'd go to work
for the phone company,
maybe work in an office.
I figured I'd work till 65
and have 1.34 kids,
I'd retire at 65
and then Iwould die at statistical
average age for my gene pool.
That's what I expected.
Until one day in 1972,
on the radio in the next room to mine,
I heard a voice that changed everything.
I was working for
the Little Rock Housing Authority,
Little Rock, Arkansas,
urban renewal agency;
I was a government clerk
making $525 a month;
I weighed 200 pounds -
this is 148 -
I smoked two packs of cigarettes a day;
I'd never set a goal in my life;
I didn't have a college degree
and no money in the bank;
I was newly married
with a new baby at home;
and I didn't expect much from life.
And in the next room,
I heard the voice of Earl Nightingale,
known at the time
as the dean of personal motivation.
He was on 900 radio stations
around the world,
and what he said that day
will forever resonate with me.
He said, "If you will spend
one extra hour each day
studying your chosen field,
you'll be a national expert
in that field in five years or less."
That hit me like a tornado;
it rearranged everything in my life.
I started doing the math:
an hour extra a day,
say five days a week, 50 weeks a year,
that's 1,250 hours over five years.
If I spent - me, just ordinary me -
1,250 hours studying one subject ...
Wow! Yeah! I could actually
be a national expert.
What I want to be an expert at?
It was not urban renewal.
(Laughter)
Then it occurred to me
a few weeks later,
I want to do what that guy
on the radio's doing.
But I had no idea what that was.
I just knew it felt right
to get in the field of human development.
I thought we'll see, an hour a day,
I am a government clerk.
I've got eight hours a day.
(Laughter)
I could do this by Thursday.
And then I started
thinking about what he'd said,
and I took him seriously, an hour a day.
I focused - I thought
I was kind of behind the game,
so I needed two hours,
and three and four and five.
So I overcompensated,
and I became fanatical
about the field of human development.
And in that five year period,
I went from being a government clerk
with very little aspiration
to being a full-time speaker and trainer.
In two years, that was 1972,
in 1974, I started buying
Earl Nightingale's training materials
and selling them to businesses.
By 1984, his company was selling
my training materials worldwide.
They sold 3.5 million dollars worth
of one of my first audio albums
in the first two years it was out.
I was blown away.
His formula works,
and I've seen it work for hundreds
and even thousands of people
in the many many years since that time
that I've been sharing that message.
Think about that.
If you were to focus one -
well, you here, a TED audience -
if you were to focus half an hour a day,
(Laughter)
extra,
just beyond the TED talk
that you always watch, right?
Every day, okay, beyond that,
if you were to focus half an hour of study
on one field of endeavor
for five consecutive years,
you'd not only transform you,
you'd transform the world around you.
And we collectively would transform
the world as we know it today.
You and I were born with the gift
to make this a better place.
Even if we didn't improve,
we can make the world better right now.
We can encourage people,
compliment people,
we could solve problems,
we could pick up trash,
we could fix things,
we could bring new ideas.
But as you grow, you become
a bigger source for the rest of life
to express itself through you.
You were put here for a reason.
It's contained in that acorn.
So nurture your nature, figure out -
First off: I am valuable, accept that.
I want to know who I am,
and I want to know how I operate
and how can I understand me better.
And then I want to nurture that nature.
I want to apply myself in the world
and put myself to work
in such ways that the rest of the world
says: "Well, that's cool.
If he or she can do it,
I could probably do it.
I wonder how they did it."
And then we start spreading that
and the ripple goes worldwide.
So ask yourself every day,
how would the person I'd like to be
do the things I am about to do?
Thank you.
(Applause)